I'll just break everything down for
everybody so you can understand how
exactly everything works I don't care
about fancy cars I don't care about big
houses I don't care about infinity pools
I care about literally none of it I
don't care about having a million
Bitcoin I don't care about uh you know
having a pet in New York City I care
about good people doing good things to
make things better because I don't like
bad things yeah and what do I see I
complain about it all day all the bad
things so let me explain how this
company Works we're very different from
big con and a lot of these companies
I wish I was the kind of guy who could
fire everybody shut the whole company
down and then just take all of that
money and put in my pocket because it is
almost entirely just me
if if
I I talk about this quite a bit
I told this to Stephen some days I think
back to when I was sitting in New Jersey
in front of my uh computer in my boxers
playing World of Warcraft I think I can
remember which one is Legion I think
uncovered the void Alps that was fun uh
unlocked and I had like 180 000
subscribers on on youtube.comcast I had
a hundred thousand on timcast news and I
was making about three hundred thousand
dollars per year just off that
and then Joe Rogan calls me up we have a
conversation then Joe Rogan invites me
out and I say this is awesome I should
totally do it sometimes I think back and
I'm like maybe I shouldn't have done it
maybe I'd like to I'd like to peer into
the crystal ball and find that timeline
where I said Joe with respect love your
work not interested have a nice day
because I'd be sitting there minding my
own business with no headaches with no
employees and I'd be making a ton of
money and then with that money I could
buy a bunch of gold bars put those gold
bars in my closet and then a year later
I look at my closet the gold bars are
sitting there so here's the thing about
these big media companies and why they
do these deals and why they offer the
contracts they do first I'll say it
again Crowder's right to say no to these
contracts he's right to say these
contracts are bad nobody should take
these deals it's a new world make your
own channel Forge your way it is
difficult but that's what has to be done
especially for someone as big as Crowder
I can certainly understand why there is
someone thinking like yeah but if I get
a job at the daily wire I could be the
next Michael knows total fact total fact
here's the thing
what do we what do we do the majority of
the money that we make here we invest in
people who don't make money back for us
and I'm not trying to say this because I
love everybody who works at timcast we
got an awesome team of really great
people and they help make it all
possible it is possible to run Tim cast
IRL on Bare Bones with maybe like one or
two people but I want to make sure
nobody's like going crazy and everyone's
comfortable so we have like a handful of
people who have we have people who book
people who who who schedule guests you
know uh uh people who uh will handle the
booking for us do the paperwork
it does require some people if I got rid
of this show and just in my own personal
YouTube channels Revenue probably
wouldn't change that much and I wouldn't
have to worry about any of this I could
take that money that I make from you
guys watching my content I could then
buy a gold bar for two thousand dollars
put in my closet close the door A year
later when I come back the gold bar is
still there that's my that's my gold bar
I will always have it yeah instead you
see but you go and you you look at that
gold bar and then you walk out of your
house and the world's on fire Tim yeah
that's the thing I'm I don't I don't
know you that well maybe 45 minutes we
spoke but I could tell the type of
person you are and you you wouldn't be
satisfied with that that's it's because
I don't care about a gold bar right so
so here's what we have we have like 35
employees plus contractors
I make a little bit of money off a bunch
of our shows
um I think cast Castle may be our second
now second most successful show because
we've got a bunch of people sign up to
become members specifically to watch the
shenanigans of the house I think that's
awesome nice
um pop culture crisis our pop culture
show in the red
makes money but in the red and you know
what I don't care but let me explain
something and I I and you know shout out
to the pop culture crisis crew you guys
do a really really great job
we pay them a salary that's guaranteed
income
I don't make that money back how could I
do a deal where I'm like I will pay you
more money or I will give you all of
these things like when a member signs up
you get a cut that's impossible yeah I'm
just losing money but I want this thing
to exist and then here's the best part
let's say I spend five hundred thousand
dollars on on this show
because I want it to exist
and then
they quit that that money's gone
crap I could buy gold bars I don't go
anywhere they don't even walk you know
just lock them in a closet what you're
investing in though is if you're
investing in intangible so like the pop
culture crisis culture that's what
you're investing in right there you
don't know what that will turn into and
then and we also look at like uh maybe
some of the ESG stuff where Disney World
fund movies that are just complete
garbage and I'm doing the same thing be
in the red but they're pushing a culture
they're pushing some they better not be
garbage Tim don't do it no no this is
what people need to get impact
investment Fox News Fox News
the daily wire uh Epoch times whatever
I'm not trying to call anybody out
specifically but they're they're in the
business of making money they of course
probably believe something like a lot of
what they're doing you wouldn't start a
business selling birdhouses unless you
like making birdhouses
but I don't need the company to make
money so this is what I'm saying about
Crowder being right what we're doing and
what Crowder needs to do is different
Crowder will will be rich for the rest
of his life he has nothing to worry
about what Crowder needs to do now is
take that those resources from those who
care about them those who respect his
voice and believe in the movement when
they buy bug club and when they invest
he needs to then do exactly what he's
saying that's why I say he's completely
right he's like I will sign you I will
get you this deal yes
because Disney is doing ESG they're
hiring woke people at a loss because
they want the politics I'll play the
same damn game
I could invest all of my money in
something much easier you know I could
call a wealth management guy and be like
look we're making eight figures take all
the money all the profit and invest it
in in BlackRock and Vanguard whatever
garbage company that wants to destroy
the planet I'm doing that
so uh you know I mentioned like we fall
on private planes I've got a Model S
I'll tell you exactly why the model is
I don't want to Model S I don't want an
expensive car
but I can't just have money sitting in
the bank that is not a reality
it devalues over time yeah especially
with the way inflation was going what
ends up happening is I'm sitting there
and we have like profit come in and I'm
like okay
I have this money that came in
I want to invest in something
we have to have a certain amount in our
savings account to run the business
because when covet happened Revenue
dropped to like we basically were
sitting on top of red and that was that
was a scary thing to see happen now I've
got 30 plus employees I can't go in the
red if we don't have that rainy day fund
right people don't get paid yeah okay
can't do that also can't just have cash
in the bank it's it's losing value and
people want raises so you have to buy
something that will retain its value so
property in any capacity well I I really
relate to your story and and this is I
think why I'm a fan of yours is because
you don't need to be doing what you're
doing in terms of fighting in the
culture war and yet you're doing it and
this is actually one of my major
disagreements with the old guard of the
libertarian party is that they they
really abdicated their Duty in terms of
engaging in the culture War at all you
know they just said let people do as
they see fit and that's not our business
we just want the government out of it
and and while obviously I agree with
that sentiment I think at the end of the
day the reason that Michael Knowles and
Matt Walsh and these other people get to
drag us through the mud and pretend as
if we're you know degenerates and we
have no uh moral Fabric or you know
culture to ourselves at all as they
should that well they should they should
be doing that but they're wrong and and
I think it's because we didn't engage in
that fight so I love that you like you
were talking on the show last night
about creating the coffee shops with the
skate shops and and having your or our
crew of media that's you know playing as
opposed to having CNN playing in the gym
and things like that exactly I think
it's so important that you're doing that
and and the other reason I relate to
your story is because I was a I ran a
private mortgage company and I was
making a half a million dollars a year
and I had no employees and I was just
raking I was just doing great and I did
that for 10 years and then the lockdowns
happened and I was like oh I've been
ignoring the insanity of our world for
too long 2020 strikes obviously lunatics
are in charge of us they lock us down
they screw up everything and I'm like
well I need to do something about this
so I shut down my company I start
liberty lockdown and then Tower gang
it's like at some point things get so
dire that we're forced to engage and and
if you want to ignore that I could have
done the same thing I could have gone
out and buyed uh bought bars of gold but
then I'm in I'm in a world that's hell
so why would I do that if I if I could
just tag on to what you were saying a
couple days ago you had the crassenstein
brothers on and they said something that
bothered me uh everything they say bye
no no something that I kind of like it
really stuck with me they said uh they
don't like that Republican legislature
is uh making laws against or focusing
too much on culture I'm probably
paraphrasing it wrong they said they
shouldn't they care too much about
social issues correct yeah that's what
they said they I mean I think that that
you guys are completely over the target
if you have pinpointed an issue in this
Society a linchpin that is well I mean
it's holding them together but you you
guys are right over it and when the left
sees that or whoever it may be when they
see that they kind of start to get
frazzled and they said it out loud which
to me was like kind of amazing but I've
I've heard it before multiple times
where you're calling someone out that's
what they're doing in does anyone ever
talk about the health care policies of
Iran
no what do they talk about
what does the left talk about when it
comes to countries like Iran or or Saudi
Arabia women's rights yeah women Optics
treatment of gay people that's true so
what happens is on the right you have
the vanguards of social order
where they're saying like guys
if we go down that path no one will ever
care about health care policy because
people will be dying the left like the
krasensteins they're more liberal
they're more default liberal they're
like I don't understand why culture
matters I'm concerned about someone
getting health care or a job and I'm
like that's Downstream from where we're
at it's I agree with you but when when
the cultural apparatus is completely on
that side there every time I open my
eyes or like if I turn on my phone or
the TV it's something from a
left-leaning cultural establishment oh
yes it's kind of hard for me to separate
these two things
so it's so monopolized I really believe
that if we don't engage in that fight
then the future Generations are owned by
their dictates and we stand no chance so
we have no choice but to engage and the
people that actually have Financial
capital or success or brand recognition
or name recognition that exists in our
space as far as I'm concerned maybe it's
altruistic maybe it's too haughty and
lofty but I think that we have a duty to
engage in their Arena the one that they
don't want us to be engaging in yeah one
of the issues up to this point the
libertarian has had I think is that it's
it's very Live and Let Live Like You Do
you according to politics like your
politics but then they also said that
about culture like whatever but the
reality is we are embedded in each
other's realities like culturally
regardless of our politics I'm so down
with letting you do your own politics
over there but if it's altering the way
my kids view their gender or or changing
the way my kids think I'm involved no
matter what my voice this is why I have
such a harsh disagreement with the
reasons and the Cato Institutes of the
world that that frame us as being
basically we are not allowed we're not
permitted by their establishment
libertarian Inc Banner to engage in this
discussion whatsoever they don't want us
to comment on you know ESG and CRT and
any of the things that are going into
our culture which is like gutting our
civilization and I take that very
seriously and most Libertarians I know
do as well so when people recognize you
know Cato or Reason as the standard
barriers for libertarianism it drives me
insane and that's why uh crowd Crowder's
done that multiple times yes but I want
to read these these we got a couple
super chats and this is a this is a
really good example of one of the
biggest problems that we have in the
culture War we got blunt news it says
Tim telling all his employees he doesn't
need them right to their face in front
of the world you're welcome to the five
dollars it's the last another guy says
Tim you need a slice a humble pie no let
me speak for that bro I got excited to
being honest with me let me remember you
basically said your employee ways are
inconsequential have some respect for
the people who took the risk but this is
the point the view of those super
Chatters is the purpose of the business
is to make money no if I'm going to do
anything in terms of leading a culture
War charge it's impossible without the
people who work at this company Bingo
the money is garbage that's the point I
don't need it I'd rather I'd rather hire
someone like Shane Cashman so that he
can write these stories and profile
people like Carrie Lake and and uh and
Kanye yeah and an article the way I've
explained it is what would I rather have
an infinity pool or for the world to be
able to read a breakdown of what
happened in that courtroom with Kerry
Lake for the world to have that article
so when when someone says like Tim
saying his employees are inconsequential
oh you misunderstand they're
inconsequential to me making money but
who the cares if I make money we all
care if fact-based news is being written
hey guess what we're News Guard
certified over timcast.com that's only
possible thanks to our Newsroom does The
Newsroom make money it makes a little
bit but I spend more on it why because
it is more important to have these
people able to do the world-changing
things they do than for me to buy gold
that's the point how about this I could
if I was that kind of guy be like I'm
the one who makes the money why do I
need anyone else for but I don't care
about that when you guys become members
of timcast.com when you guys Super Chat
I'm basically saying who else can I
Empower to try and change the world yeah
and it really is crazy
and I think about it I'm like man
like some of the stuff that's been
produced by like you know shout out to
Shane Cashman the news team pop culture
crisis I'm like this stuff is going to
last forever and it is infinitely more
valuable than any material object the
abstract ideas that are produced and I
gotta give a shout out to Shane because
I think him profiling the Cary Lake
trial is a piece of history that needed
to exist and I am eternally grateful
that you guys watching made that
possible thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time